Film Courage: What are some common ways people get
their own stories wrong? StoryWorksLA Writer and Coach Barbara Seymour Giordano: That is a very
interesting question that I hadn't
really thought of. The ways that people
get their story wrong? I would say when
it comes to getting your story wrong
is you don't have a really clear
perception of who you are and where you
are and so when that's out of step and
out of alignment and that usually occurs
when there's too much ego or too much
fragility you know you're on a spectrum
right so you're either oh I can't do
that right or you know there's a lot of
false bravado so when it gets too
extreme in either direction is when the
story gets wrong it gets warped and what
we tell ourselves becomes our beliefs
right and then those beliefs are the
things that keep us stuck so it's really
important to take a look at how much ego
do I have in this you can feel it in
your body
was it Sanford Meisner that said the
body is the instrument I believe it was
the acting coach and excuse me YouTube
world if I got that wrong but I believe
he was the one that said that and which
is brilliant because I say that to my
speakers you know and I quote him and
hopefully it's the right one but you can
really feel in your skin when you're
when you're in alignment and when you're
in alignment you are telling your truth
and that truth is short sweet and to the
point it doesn't take a lot of words to
say and it has the tone and the beauty
and the magic of a church bell I I don't
live very far from the the San Juan
mission and every hour they ding the
bell right and the sound it's an old
beautiful church bell and the sound is
pure and gorgeous
that's what truth feels like you can
feel that in your body there's no
resistance its when we feel resistance
in our body that we're not being true to
our story
or who we are I should say you know the
story we're telling but it doesn't mean
that we're being true to who we are or
what we could be and sometimes things
will feel false when we start to try to
tell stories in a new way because we've
been we've worn out those steps right
you've created a groove and the steps if
you've ever been to an like let's say to
the the White House you can see the
steps and when you go inside and take
the tour there's marble steps and
they're all worn right those those
grooves there that's what we do when we
tell the same story over and over we
create these grooves and they feel
comfortable and you know that they're
gonna be worn that way but then when we
start to realize that story doesn't fit
us anymore and we take new steps over
into the place that's level all of a
sudden that doesn't oh I'm not used to
that maybe I'm lying but but eventually
it will become true and you'll know that
that's where you want to be and it will
push you and it will become your new
normal and it will resonate with you
that way but most of the time I find
when people are out of alignment with
their story and they're not being really
true to who they are and what they want
to be then they'll feel it in their
bodies have you ever had to have a
meeting about that in terms of you you
know meet the person you find out kind
of their line of events and what their
agenda is or you know what their what
their startup is but then there's just
something off about the story and you
have to let them know it's a disconnect
and I'm really sorry and then of course
there'd be resistance of course if
anybody was told that about their own
lives but and then trying to sort of
work with them on allowing what you see
as a real story to come forward yes
that's very observant so both in the
pitch world when I work with
entrepreneurs and in a speech writing
world there are for the for the
the entrepreneurs often it's that
they're so early-stage they can't see
all of the all of the things they need
to see yet right because it's an
evolution right you progress along the
way and your story gets tighter and
tighter and tighter and you fill those
holes you pitch where you are and then
the next pitch will never be the same as
the first one or it will be there'll be
elements that are the same but hopefully
you will have grown the company and so
it will have evolved along with you so
it's important as an entrepreneur to
continually iterate but what happens is
because I know the stories the story
forms so well those rules that I so
resisted I've really come in and II that
I can hear when there's in there's
something incongruent
right so when there's this there's a
hole and I'm saying to and I've had as a
result of me grilling the entrepreneur
so deeply they are like okay what does
this lady gonna let up on me but then
they will have actually once they
realize that that the question I'm
asking is just an audience question that
it's not making sense your startup that
you keep saying you're gonna go to this
target market but I don't see it with
the product that you have so when things
don't fit together just from an average
person looking at it right because I'm
not an expert in their field that's
actually my strength is I'm not an
expert in someone's field but I can so
that makes me be able to hear even more
so when something doesn't fit together
and so what happens is they have to go
and back to the drawing table and look
at why it's not working and I've had
quite a few companies pivot as a result
meaning that they've had to go and
revamp their product and the market that
they were going toward so it would be
more in alignment and it's helped them
so that's been a big epiphany because
they were sure that that was the
direction that they were supposed to be
going in so it's often that's just blind
spots that they can't see right so that
becomes very clear to me
the audience when it comes to my
speakers in their own personal stories
that boils down a lot to the their
relationship to those stories are they
willing to let go of a story that the
way that they've been telling it when
Amy came to me she had been telling she
only been speaking to high schools for
an hour so she had times at time 8
minutes was a big departure so we had to
get really serious as I joke with my
speakers it's time to pull out the
chainsaw remember fire it up and carve
right but that allows things to rise to
the top so when when I sit down with the
speaker let's say you come to me and say
Barbara I've got a 10 minute talk and I
say okay great
why don't you give me what you think you
want to talk about in 1,300 words and so
you'll write me 1300 words and from that
I'll upload it to Google Docs and then
I'll dissect it and ask alright all of
these questions that I'll highlight them
and you and I'll sit down for an hour
and a half and we'll go through one by
one and because of that reason of
talking on the surface like I was
mentioning when we communicate that's
how most people write when they're not
writers and even writers do write and so
I keep going deeper because I'm
emotionally demanding as I tell my
speakers I want to know how you feel how
you felt in that moment where you were
you know let me feel that - don't be
stingy and so a lot of times people
won't tell me a full story and I'll say
to them I feel like you're hiding
something and they'll be like what how
did you know and now because it will
what's not there
will tell me what's missing omission
omission it's lying by omission and so
it's not that people are inherently
lying but I can feel something's not
right I feel very very deeply when
people have secrets
it's it comes it it bounces I don't know
what the secret is but it comes flying
off the page of me right or in
conversation because I have to go deep
with my speakers and I'll feel when
they're not opening up because when
you're an open book it's fluid right you
know we were just talking about this the
other day David and I in terms of
certain people and interviews are
willing to go to certain lengths and
other people only want to present all
the things that are positive they don't
ever want to go into struggles that they
had and why certain people's sort of
fall into that camp and why others are
just like like you said open books and
they're willing to say you know I was
sleeping on a couch and there was no
money in the bank and my life is over
and I think there's there something
where certain people don't want to tell
certain parts of their story because
there's a lot of shame behind it and so
but sometimes those are the things that
make you connect to them they make you
connect to a story whether it's a script
and then there's a character that's not
telling something so do you often see
with maybe people that are you know
advanced degrees or whatever they don't
want to go into failure but sometimes
that component of failure is really
what's gonna just make you connect in
the audience in that eight minutes yeah
I say to my speakers there is no story
without struggle period if you don't
have a struggle we can just close the
books now and say goodbye because we all
had struggle and I like to go into those
more micro moments so you know how I
said that I take story and I really make
it narrow for my speakers and I
consolidate it so it's not a lot a bunch
of stories it's not too big it's not too
high it is very very concise so we can
go into the the story and how it made
them feel which is again giving the
audience permission to say oh that
happened to me too right and then you're
having this connection because they say
that when you feel what you're saying
you actually your brain waves send out
something that's what the tyent says
right now that the audience's brain
waves are in sync with you
but it's a feeling that's then kind of
mind control obi-wan Kenobi but it's
it's deeper than that and it's it's
satisfying feeling but so there's that
there's also when I work with executives
sometimes because there's a there's a
narrative that we Americans have which
is the individual and the individual
reigns supreme that's a lot of why
people don't want to talk about their
struggles they just want to talk about
all of their triumphs and how great they
are and how much they've achieved you
know it's a it's a reason why there are
ghost writers and speech writers are not
so different than ghost writers right
most speech writers do not identify
themselves but I do I sell my speakers
I'm going to let people know that's that
you're working with a speech writer
because that's what I do but most
feature writers won't more and more
ghost writers are starting to put their
names on book covers now but they didn't
in the past and people feel threatened
by that
so that again if that's an ego issue and
if you feel like you can't tell people
that you're working with a speech writer
who helped elevate your story it's your
story in the end right but what we
speech writers are here to do and good
storytellers are here to do as I tell my
speakers I'm here to make you look good
right I'm here too and I think also
there's an element of fear for people
they don't want to talk about struggle
what if I tell it wrong what if I over
share what if I and and so my speakers
will tell me a lot of personal details
that will never go from the page to the
stage it won't even make the page right
but it helps me understand their journey
and empathize even more deeply with them
and connect with them and that then I
filter through it so the audience feels
the tension feels the pain but they
didn't over share in a way that was like
oh that was uncomfortable awkward right
and I think people worry about that and
you know we put a lot of emphasis on
brand these days with all these social
media with all the social media
platforms and I think that it's
important to kind of walk that fine line
to be able to share hey I'm having a bad
day and here's what happened you know
and that's how we connect without the
struggle who cares so is that something
that you've had to work with certain
people on in terms of letting go and
allowing certain things that maybe they
don't think are as favorable and don't
want them out there but in in the bigger
scheme of their story the bigger you
know like picture of it that you feel
it's necessary to get our audience
empathy as well my speakers have been
pretty good on a spectrum they've been
pretty good at embracing the struggle
aspects at first especially the ones
that tend to be engineers not all of
them I love my engineer peeps too
depending on you know who they are
one I worked with once that was a doctor
and an engineer yes and so he was having
a little bit of problem embracing the
struggle but then once he he could step
back and looked at it and he was like oh
wait a minute oh I see I read this to my
wife and she was like that's really good
I really never knew it did before
right and then now all of a sudden now
there's an emotional component because
when we can tell a story especially in a
highly expert category high expert
category whether it's medicine
mathematics it doesn't matter what it is
if we can put that story into real-world
context we don't need to know the fine
point details you can go and give that
PowerPoint presentation to your fellow
mathematicians right but but how do you
let that how do you translate that for
mere mortals like myself to understand
how what you do has real-world
implications and that you struggled to
get to that you just didn't sit down one
day and say oh I'm going to be a field
medalist and become this fabulous
mathematician and this is how I'm gonna
do it no you sucked a lot along the way
and it was painful and your peers
spanked you along
and you know really beat up on you and
still you persevered because you knew
that you had something and you had to
keep going you know it's not easy
so that struggle to varying degrees
some people totally get it and embrace
it like yes and others are like lukewarm
but this still go along with it because
usually somebody higher up has hired me
if I'm working with people that are
academics and I will defer I'll say well
you know your boss the Dean will have
said you need to do it this one they're
like all right or or you know whoever
the the vice-chancellor of the school
those kinds of things I work a lot with
the universities so
you